what's up bro how are you I'm pretty
good man pretty good how are you yeah I
hope you get paid enough bro God takes
care of me man for real man seriously
you doing a lot of work man
thanks listen man I love my black
Brothers you know in the United States I
I used to live in America years ago you
did are you in the United States yeah
yeah I'm in the US yeah man that was my
spot bro yeah for sure for sure where
you where are you now I lived there for
about like 12 years I went to
college and what country do you live in
now huh what country do you live in now
Al Jerusalem oh okay nice yeah yeah you
like it not that very nice I'll tell you
that oh that's okay man well you're
alive man you're alive you're kicking
you're smiling that's good
right well I mean you don't see that
smile at all oh
we we're living in poverty bro okay
we're living in in in occupation you
know it's really tough I'm telling you
where do you live in the US what state
I'm from California California yeah
that's a nice yeah I went to California
one time it was beautiful yeah I love it
I love California beautiful man yeah
yeah so you're you're a Muslim right I
mean listen we're all we're
all you know what the word Islam means
for real do you really know I've heard
it means
surrender Islam is peace man that's what
it is well that's not what the word
means yeah is Islam Salam meaning peace
what makes you believe that Islam is
peace well I'm living in peace I'll tell
you that with the uh ideology of Islam I
live in peace I'm very comfortable I
don't really have to question
I'll tell you what I'll I'll bring it to
you this way if if you're sitting in a
meeting right and someone comes in and
tells you oh I lost after the meeting is
over of course and he says I lost my
wallet and then you asked around there
was about 20 people in the meeting hey
guys did anybody find a wallet yeah
there's a wallet right here right and if
nobody claims that wallet that means
this guy's telling the truth
right unless somebody else and says no
this guy is a liar this is my wallet and
I got $20 in it and I got two credit
cards from Bank of America and I got
this this this and that you know what I
mean someone to prove
otherwise which is very logic right I
mean it's a logic
thing so how doeses chisanity how does
that tie in and
jism they're religion from God you know
I don't I don't disagree that they're
religion from God but I disagree with
that the Jews are the
chosen uh people for God and I really
don't think that's fair honestly the
Quran says that he says that at one
point when there was only Jews no there
were multiple people on the planet no it
was multiple people but they were
nonbelievers the only ones that they
were Believers were the Jews well he
made he said that the Jews are the
people that he favored over above
mankind so all mankind tell you at that
time of course yeah he doesn't he
doesn't limit it to that time where
where does he like change his mind I
mean you know the time that the Allah
subhanahu wa taala mentioned that to the
Muslims that this is what happened back
in the day when the first people to
believe in were the Jews were the
children of Israel yeah but where where
does where does where does all first
people who believed in where does Allah
change his mind that like oh they were
his people and now they're not his
favored people where does he change his
mind in the look I mean look you can see
man I'll tell you what when when
something's dark
brother you can tell it's dark no matter
how you try to paint it is dark man you
know what I mean that's why I reject
Islam I'm gonna give you a small example
with all respect I don't no no no no
that's what I'm what I'm asking for is
where where in the Quran does like does
it change I was driving one time hey
palestin please what I'm what I'm asking
is is where in the Quran does it
indicate does it say that Allah has
changed his mind on the Israelites being
his favorite people among mankind
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he advised us that this is what
the story and like I said the only one
who claimed to have that wallet which is
Prophet Muhammad nobody came afterwards
to prove otherwise well I need need to
see but that that doesn't change the
fact that the Jews are his favorite
people among mankind just because
Muhammad comes around I don't I don't I
don't see a change in the Quran in that
do you know what the word means what
does that mean a brother means it's like
I can't say I can't sit here on live
saying I I think I'm talking to logic
because I I'm it's not that I think I am
this is something I am sure about the
meaning I think meaning I believe in
something that it's
unknown and that's what Muslims believe
in the unknown it is unknown to them
they believe in it deeply and that's
called and there's no way it's like a
tie and you cannot untie it so how how
how does that tie in with uh what I'm
asking you say it again how does that
tie in with what I'm asking you oh
because like I said said Prophet
Muhammad came and told us that I I
didn't see I didn't see that the Jews
were God's favorite but where where
where does Muhammad say that they're
like that they're not his favorite
anymore well there's a lot of Muhammad
doesn't say himself he speaks the words
of Allah and Allah in the Quran did
mention that okay yeah that's what I'm
asking for I'm asking for where where
does Allah in the Quran mention that the
Jews are no longer his favorite people
the Quran it says uh let me think of it
hold on one second brother I think I
know
[Music]
it meaning do not have them as their as
your superiors the Jews and the nasara
what verse is
this
uh I don't know that's the verse so
you're talking about well the verse
actually says do not you're talking
about do not take the Jews and
Christians as
friends not as friends
asah superiors no it doesn't mean
superiors yeah aah is superiors I have a
lot of friends man that they're Jews and
I have a lot of friends that they're
Christians and you're going against the
Quran that is not true because the Quran
don't say that so where in where in that
verse does it say that the Jews are not
the favorite where where in that verse
does it say that the Jews are not
Allah's favored people anymore
well he's telling me not to be my
superiors that means you know no that's
not what he's saying that's not what
he's saying at all it doesn't literally
say it but it says do not have them as
your superiors no it doesn't Aliah does
not mean superiors it means friends
allies that's what it means oh no
brother aah is superiors is not friends
okay well I I don't want to spend I
don't want to spend uh like because you
know Muslims can do this all day uh
what what is uh I need a reason why you
said that like Islam is
peace everywh you look at it is peace
everywh anywh you look at it is peace
okay do you do you believe that it's do
you believe that it's peaceful to to the
African-American uh color I'll tell you
that why did Muhammad had people of the
African-American color as slaves then
I'll tell you what in one incident there
was two or three or four slaves that
they were taken but they were not really
black slaves they were slaves because
slaves were not just blacks okay I'm
talking about the black slaves that
Muhammad bought and sold off why why did
he why was he buying and selling off
black slaves he had he had few slaves
some of them are white some of them are
black now he exchanged do slave with two
slaves that they were captured in a war
noit out of them no that never happened
he sold two black slaves for one non
black slave he exchanged them for one
yeah so he sold or he bought the one
slave the one the one nonblack slave for
hold hold on please please please if I
can if I can finish the Hadith literally
says that he bought him bought the
nonblack slave for two for two black
slaves bring that up I can assure you
that is not true sure he exchanged he
freed one slave okay he freed him from
his no he didn't owner at the time no he
didn't why would why would he listen
he's not a bad businessman he's not
stupid either I would not exchange one
for two or two for one well that's the
cost the C the cost the cost was uh that
a non-black slave was worth higher and
worth more than a black slave that's the
point that's the racism in there they're
both black what are you talking about no
they were not black uh yes they were one
meaning black okay let's pull up the
Hadith and see pull up the
brother all right Sun nasai 4184 it says
a slave came and pledged to the prophet
to
immigrate and the prophet did not
realize and the prophet did not realize
that he was that he was a slave excuse
me then his master let me share my
screen on you YouTube so you guys can
see it as well I mean you guys already
know this stuff but you know for those
who are seen this for the first time
there you
go then his master came looking for him
the prophet said sell him to me and he
the prophet bought him literally where
I'm reading off the page bought him for
two black
slaves then he did not accept the pledge
from anyone until he asked is he a
slave so Muhammad was buying and selling
black slaves
man brother that's mistranslated I can
assure you that mistranslated that's not
how it is in Arabi yeah that's not how
it is that's exactly how it is ask any
Arabic person to translate what you just
said know that Hadith and he will tell
you exactly what I'm telling you for
sure yeah let me um Let me let me see
any any Arabic speakers in here just one
second let's do that we got we actually
have that any Arabic speakers here Paul
bishop
or uh any of my any any of my Arab
arabic speaking brothers and sisters
please come on up they're going to
they're going to switch the words Arab
Christians they're gonna switch the said
any Arab person any person that speaks
Arabic that's what you said yes he will
read it to you the way I read it no I
think that every Arab probably an Arab
Muslim might try to do what you're doing
which is changing the words of the
text I think we need a non-biased person
here thank you for the Super Chat T
cannot be changed the
filthy with Prophet Muhammad free most
of the slaves why why would he buy one I
mean just common sense right who did he
free least Fair who did he free why
would he
freees oh he encouraged all his sahab
all his
friends to free slaves Abu Bak the first
who did who you said that Muhammad freed
slaves who did he free
oh uh I'll tell you who it did uh what's
his name um Muhammad
um
um can't think of the names right now
but he freed a lot of them he didn't
free any
slaves yes he did he didn't free bow he
did not free bow and no you know what's
what's his name I meant
uh yes so why is why is Muhammad buying
and owning and selling
black slaves brother why would you say
buying not because it says that he then
he sell him to me and he bought him for
two black slaves so he sold off two
black slaves to buy a non-black slave
why is he selling black people that is
that is not true brother the truth is
not that is not true it's a at least for
people to respect your show and your
life you know at least it's got to be
fair you know what I mean and
it'sah you know it has to be fact check
it's not just speaking words that
someone taught you that is not true
brother I'm telling I'm just reading off
the Hadith man so so are they lying is
is sun on the side they're
lying do you know what theith is do you
know what Hadith means yeah we don't we
don't got to do that are they lying is
sunai lying brother is is talk okay
people change talk from time to time
yeah are they lying is my question some
of them yeah some of them were caught
lying yes so all right so so sun nasai
is lying so guys for you guys who are
asking this is Sun nasai
4184 hold on hold on please I'm I'm
talking proud proud Palestinian I'm
talking please so for the audience
that's asking for the Hadith number this
is Sun anai 4184 its grade is sah you uh
you have multiple of the same narration
in sunai you have Sun nasai 4184 that's
one I just read you have the other one
that's
4621 sunai 4621 great sah says the same
exact
thing you know Sunan iban Maja 2869
great sahi says the same thing he bought
him in exchange for two black slaves n
it's not bought brother that's what it
says that's what it is that's what it
says okay can you read oh oh here here
it is and John me termity John me term
you 239 if you don't like the word
bought here's here's J it says tell me
what's the word bought yeah it says so
he purchased him for two black slaves no
I want you to pronounce it in Arabi if
you don't mind I don't need
to
so can you I don't need to I just read
it if you want to throw your scholars in
Hadi under the bus that's on you says in
theith Prophet
Muhammad meaning bought he bought them
he purchased them purchased him for two
black slaves my friend there's no way
around it so how how is how is this
friendly you want to believe it it's up
to you but I can only believe what I
read bro I can only believe what I read
exactly I can only believe what I read
man but you reading something that it's
false brother I mean these people right
so the Islamic sources are false no
absolutely I'm telling you the false is
who translated it yeah so the Muslim the
Muslim translators who's translating the
Hadith are false got it if if if they
claim to be Muslims yes they are false
man we can't we can't uh we can't trust
anything H we can't trust anything the
Muslims do brother I am Muslim and I'm
telling you that's not true you're
telling me it's not true because you
have a bias towards Muhammad you're
saying that it's not true because you
have a bias towards Muhammad PR
Palestinian proud Palestinian you have a
bias towards the source that's why
you're disagreeing with it you don't
don't have any real reason that you're
disagreeing with it I can listen bring
it up on your camera it says in Arab let
me see bring it okay I challenge you to
bring it in Arabi all
right I shall do as you request my
friend thank
you
man I shall do as you request thank you
guys for the super
chats even for those who are coming up
paying the jiz of non-christians even
giving super chats I appreciate
you all
right
here it
is let me try to I don't know maybe I
don't know can I shrink
this I'll read it I'll read it trust me
you can read this and I'm not
embarrassed to read it yeah right go
ahead I'm not
embarrassed okay go
ahead I can't see it very far but let me
see meaning told
us he said that have
said based on AB speech meaning there's
three people so
far that's the fourth one
okay move to the right
yeah meaning a slave came and wanted to
submit to Prophet
Muhammad to travel with him to immigrate
to
Medina
okay and then what happens I don't see
the rest of it and to the
left
oh and
even Prophet Muhammad he did not believe
at that point that he was a slave he
thought he was
freed yeah to the left
please then his his owner
came that he wanted him like he wanted
him he he probably holler at him or
something then Prophet Muhammad said
go
[Music]
ahead sell him to me
right meaning he submit to
me oh it said sell him to me right no he
said meaning he submit to
me pleas please please that
please don't please don't lie in your
text the text says sell him to me
correct Mohammed told him to sell him to
him closer can you get it
closer uh let me
see let see
uh
I don't know this this this won't really
work like this let me um let me try it
this way hold
on yeah let's let's try to be honest
with the text man all
right all right you good
here is this
good
PR
Palestinian I see it yes does it say
sell him to
me it
says
he bought him now the the Rahi you know
the person who's telling the Hadith it
says that Prophet Muhammad bought him
exactly that's what I said yeah but
that's the person who's telling the
Hadith that doesn't mean that's exactly
what happened I'm not trying to to
really tell you that he bought him that
means that's exactly what happened my
friend no Prophet what well okay I'll
tell I'll tell you something what would
Prophet Muhammad benefit of buying a
slave seriously well he bu he he he he
he has the he has the willpower to do it
man he could do whatever he wants he's
the prophet no why would he do it why
would he do it he has whatever it
doesn't matter why would he do it who
cares no listen if I do something I got
have to benefit out of who cares man the
fact is that your
Prophet Millions he didn't need a slave
to serve him well he had him if he
bought him to free
him he had him he didn't buy him to free
him if he if he's if if he bought look
my my friend my friend if he if he
bought him to free him why didn't he
just free the two black slaves as well
then because they were captured like I
said in in the war no what wait where do
you get that from what do you mean where
did I get from that's where they were
these two no that's not where they were
like any other ones yeah no that's not
true at all man and they didn't want to
submit to Allah so for Prophet
Muhammad to anyone who would making this
up as you go anything he has you're
making this up as you go
brother I'm telling you this is what it
is so remember you remember you told me
to be remember you told me to be honest
right remember you told me to be honest
right you told me to be honest to the
text me ask you something you told wait
wait wait a second you told me to be
honest to the text and honest to the
source that I'm using for the audience
right yes so was was I was I telling the
truth no you were telling the truth of
course I'm not gonna deny that you were
telling the truth thank you I appreciate
that yeah I know but you also have to
remember one thing like let's say
billionaire why would a billionaire
let's say buy uh Maids maids and
servants let's say maids and servants
exactly why would a billionaire that has
a lot of servants go by a slave he
continues they they continue to do that
why why would billionaires continue to
buy more servants maids and servants
guys that's what they
do billionaires literally have
billionaires literally have servants
bils my friend that whether whether or
not you want to argue Muhammad's motive
it doesn't matter Prophet Muhammad was a
very simple person but that doesn't
matter to me that doesn't matter to me
your Prophet your Prophet was selling
black
people and and andash was a slave he
freed him and he made him F FOC
your Prophet was selling black people
how is this okay for me as a black
person to to try to believe in a prophet
who was selling my people okay listen
logic let's listen this is really a fact
okay these we're talking facts now all
right who brought millions of Africans
as slave to the United States and Europe
was the church was had nothing to do
with the church and and now and now hey
hey guys put up the poll put up the poll
it's time put up the poll
the PO does he stay or go I mean he
can't he can't
engage can't
engage you have nothing to say about
your Prophet selling people like me he's
not selling bro you just read it he was
not selling he you just read it if he
bought any slaves you just read it black
or non blacks to free them you just read
it slaves because Islam came to teach
us it's enough of that
you just read it and you told me to be
honest but now you're being dishonest
with your own text for some reason now
you're lying about what your Prophet did
I wonder why it amazes me that the
Christians are honest about what
Muhammad does and the Muslims they gotta
fabricate they gotta lie they gotta
dance they gotta
color everybody vote at the top does he
stay or does he
go vote at the top does Our Guest stay
or does he go 8 seconds left oh believe
me they're going to say
stay I hope so and and your
Administration who's giving you
instruction those Arab zionists
unfortunately we' got 107 votes 83% says
you got to go man sorry about that I
gotta move on to the next guest have a
good night Sir you too have a good night
man yeah